hey guys how's it going so there has
been a lot about rumors over a weekend
and I didn't get a chance to make a
video so here we are today Monday
morning I woke up brush my hair got from
your Vermont and I said let's talk about
the new iPhone eight the first thing I
want to address is again a lot of these
are just rumors but I'm excited because
I basically live to these rumors because
why not this first article this is on
Forbes and this is iPhone 8-week
explains apples expensive and new
smartphone about this era thinking that
the new iPhone eight will be at least a
thousand dollars which is pretty crazy
but here's the kicker
most of the iPhones that I've purchased
in the past unfortunately because I do
upgrade so often I end up having to pay
full price for my iPhone and take you
back off that it's mostly because I
would always get the highest capacity
version phone which is way more
expensive which in return makes my phone
a thousand dollars so here's what I'm
concerned about so if the base price
iPhone is already going to be probably a
thousand dollars but will that mean if
you're out of contracts even though
people aren't doing contracts anymore
I'm so confused at how low the phone
industry is doing these things because
it doesn't ever seem to make sense I
feel like I'm a pretty knowledgeable
person but every time I go in to help my
mom or wait grandmother or anybody else
try to get a phone
like they're making things extremely
complicated and nothing ever really
makes sense it's like so wait a minute
so I'm not actually buying my phone I'm
just giving you money and then I getting
my phone back after I completely paid
for it so that I can buy another phone
does that make sense
no so now once iPhone 8 this is
interesting to me because it seems like
they're going to be releasing three
phones this year if these rumors are
correct
so Apple design of the iPhone 8 will be
the only 2017 I phoned integrate
wireless charging now what does that
mean because right now I just had a
double check the date just to make sure
it was 2017 and I wasn't going crazy
technically I only should be released
next year because the iPhone 7 just came
out was it make the next phone
technically an iPhone 7s an iPhone 7s
plus if that's the case what's going on
here so the company
early steering premium iPhones the
isolate some say what we call the iPhone
X which I hope I hope that it is if it's
called the icon next I'm going to be so
happy I'm going to throw a frequent
party I'm going to have a party for the
phone which is probably strange but if
you guys know me that's not very strange
just a really normal behavior the iPhone
7s the iPhone 7s plus and hopefully the
iPhone next will have a radical redesign
deliver the 10th anniversary of your
iPhone while the other team will stay is
the same I think this makes sense but I
do feel like they're going to sort of
alienate their audience if they release
three separate phones people are already
confused as to which phone to get and
there's too much of a camera difference
between the smaller seven and a seven
plus what I think is kind of unfair like
just put the dual camera in both phones
some people like the smaller phone form
factor whereas I do prefer having two
plus I like be able to have all the
screen real estate I like to watch
movies I like to basically do everything
on my phone I live on this phone and I'm
pretty sure it's probably the reason
that I've had a migraine for the past
week and a half because my face is
always on it that's something that I
need to work on going back to talking
about money yes this is an extremely
expensive thing phones are becoming
extremely expensive but they are slowly
replacing it computers we used to buy
computers for like $1000 now instead of
buying a computer granted were probably
not buying computers every year and the
quick turnaround time as we are with
phones
I mean like my sister doesn't even have
a computer Jenna doesn't because she got
her stolen the breanne she is pretty
much like one of those everyday people
that I feel like I usually categorize
her as the normal person she doesn't use
a computer she basically uses her phone
she uses her everything here's an
example in a soda here of what the
wireless charging could look like it
basically looks exactly like what the
Apple watch charging looks like and
there was something also that I've read
that they were talking about how since
the iPhone 7 and the iPhone 7 asks what
you'll be doing be wireless charging
there would be some sort of an adapter
that you could do this is also something
that I feel like this is a no-no
an iPhone 7s 7x plus will not include
the Lightning - 3.5 millimeter headphone
jack subscribe to the iPhone
seven-plus previously that's a no-no
because those things are so freakin
cheap to make that if you don't include
that in the stupid box that's perfect
but there is a good chance that it could
be USBC charging but for a lot of people
we've still got all the whitening tables
and in rest you have a new Mac most
people are not desperate to get us PC
like I am just give us that go home
that's not even my phone to be fair
since I've got my air pods I really have
not been stressed at all about the
particular five millimeter headphone
jack because I'm really like my ear pods
I have given them so much crap and I've
made fun of them so many times but man
they're really really great I just wish
they'd stay to my ears a little bit
better but hey you know Dee Jim just
minor details let's go to another
article with some way too much time on
that no need to wait for guess what each
of the wireless phone charging today I
mean that looks terrible so basically
you buy this receiver is no longer
available Wow look at the point I'm just
going to wait until it's actually
integrated into my phone and until then
I'm okay plugging in my phone well this
is pretty interesting it shows that they
are trying to increase the battery of
the next iPhone which will hopefully be
an OLED iPhone there's our battery and
here's the battery of the 2017 like no
wait the OLED is probably going to be
the iPhone age and not the iPhone 7s I
mean who really knows we don't know it's
just rumors guys something also along
the lines of phones is a Verizon is now
having an unlimited data plan which they
used to have and my little sister used
to be on that one but then they
basically force everyone to not have it
anymore and then they didn't have it
t-mobile was basically truly bright and
all this weekend and it was really
really funny if I thought what's also
pretty interesting it's Apple watch
series too if there's a little
commercial and it's called
closed ear rings which is kind of weird
I mean the visuals are kind of cool and
the concept is pretty neat as well but I
feel like Apple advertising lately has
been
mm real weak and hey this is coming from
a true Apple fan I just have to be
honest I know you like things that I'm
this fanatic Appleton and yet trust me
but yeah you're right I am but some
things do upset me and you know coming
from my entire life I'm basically
dedicated to loving Apple it just hurts
to see things that you weren't loved and
cared about just slipping through your
fingers and there's nothing that I can
do when I wish that I could and I am
just me I don't work for Apple I love
them so much and I just wish that they
love me back
really vicious relationship it's not
healthy at all what the guys I hope
you're all doing well I just want to say
hello and hope you guys had a wonderful
weekend and I look forward to signing
out some more about the iPhone eight I
think it's going to be super interesting
if they do end up releasing it three
phones at the same time and one
especially with such a high price point
how much is that actually going to cost
to buy the most expensive version I
don't know pretty crazy I'll see you
guys in the next video bye yeah I will
definitely be saving one of these for
myself oh you know what I should do I
should use one of my candies that I made
from a previous video oh nothing says I
love you like a chocolate poop Oh
[Music]
credible